I would start with the emergency
evacuation announcement please note that
this meeting will be audio recorded
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the room
by the door to the fire escape staircase
please hold both handrails in case the
stairs wet or slippery if anyone is
unable to use the stairs but they please
allow others to exit the room before
they go to the fire escape door where
they can then be given assistance our
assembly will be in the public car park
at the side of the circle suite please
do not delay your evacuation protecting
longings please do not return to the
building until give them something to do
so by the council staff okay and
apologies for absence I have Cal so mrs.
butcher helps here mrs. clean yes
casually John the Griffin not sure well
then that's it supposes liver shouldn't
be long as the painting she didn't she's
down resting on the queasy that's really
good at it that's gonna be there I've
raised the issue which the young leader
the perception feeding non-members at
emily is castle stepson thank you for
attending them with grab desperate
reckoned up to officer corrosion mr.
Stratton and DN on his own and she's
bridge Dragovich thank you the new
assistant directors for canadian housing
so thank you a hot pot remember the
range can do not forget
minutes of the meeting held on 30 box
2015 Weinstein both mixolydian deflate
mystery
hey
so I'm thinking
new button five to receive declarations
of interest no declarations of action we
move on to item 5 usually a critical for
this one this is the car parking
character consider their equal to the
director on the options proposed both
busy for adjustments to the car park
intera all right there it's just love
the way of sending it the recommendation
on page five point two items 7.1 it's
too it is proposed to the committee
resolves to note the contents of the
report and determine whether in any item
should be put forward for consideration
through the preparation of the 2016-17
budget so there were a number of items
picked out by the review committee which
we thought deserve consideration or and
I think they're adequately summarized in
3.1 and I think the costings are shown
the United 5.1 so basically free parking
after 6pm with a cost estimate of 30,000
pounds free parking all day saturday by
that's for every saturday in the year
cost implication of 150,000 pounds free
parking for blue badge holders blue bear
shoulders sorry not to know that's never
really been I don't think it's possible
to adequately find out what causes left
and free parking for to set aside for
Christmas look a bit cost of 4,000
pounds so what I think I'm listening
rooms
was making else added to that underneath
them and now I could open up even to
comment with relating those four should
go through or a lot of those four so it
counts the little room gone sorry that
if the grants missed him a lot
statistics fresh John Griffin Tessa
Griffin our tomato dressing you about
concern for free parking on that
Saturday and I have to support these
views as well on the basis that we've
made a tremendous amount of concessions
regarding over the last twelve monthly
writing talk in my buyers other and free
parking with diabetes too much he'd
asked me to please do for your taken
North kept stirring ground and I'd
support that view and mostly the air in
the area graphs to parking in the
district was fully debated last year the
decision came to I would support the
fries free parking after 6pm of the
ideas of the especially in rayleigh the
nighttime economy and and I would also
support the free parking because after
Christmas but the other 2i can't export
he also get some mason I agree with
everything that's been said before hand
I wouldn't think that its economic to
consider free all day Saturday I've
always felt that parking should be free
after six pm and in fact I raised that
matter more than four years ago it was
promised it would come back within six
months that's a long time so I'm up for
that and to free parking days Tuesday's
after Christmas I think would fit in
nicely with our traders new year sighs
okay so constrained it's just one caveat
they obviously there if there is already
I think an agreement for the floor set
it is prior to Chris has to be very near
afternoon Jones better i think this is
this i will confess this is another the
idea of the free parking too settled in
operational zone mentioned that
previously i think specifically that
came from councillor blank for the
location balance but i don't say what i
think is up at the moment so did you
have anyone else obsessing so i guess i
hate the pencil hazelwood thinner
I also think we should support please
watch it so I think we should support
the blue band members getting framed RV
because ultimately they are
disadvantaged and we should give them
some consideration and because obviously
they need party more than some of the
residents I feel so I do some free car
parking so it gets expensive like know
how much is going to cost if you change
the parking meters from seven to six
that's a good cost was in there for
signs and for could them I think I did
see I'm not really I don't know and I
was just scuttled could prefer if the
person clicking the tape thing is 10,000
so it's a lot of money yeah Jim
apologies i was getting on saying sorry
i wasn't trying to catch runaways that's
the m even 5.2 it says the cost X
estimating changing the car parking all
the size etc site costs about 10,000
pounds okay include the costs of
changing the matrix pro from seven to
six pm or is that you either cruel the
nest area that's that that's affordable
yet but only the cost is X making the
sauce in the website and its advertising
which
there was expensive although i would
guess given that we only ever put a
knife or notice on the four christmases
before four christmases the four
Saturdays before christmas already
better the cost for that one wouldn't be
too great Boise the parking order is the
kokino is the key cost how much use I
don't know what that you don't know
sorry a survivor okay break that okay so
yeah blue badge holders well don't you
by Rayleigh must have been bad she
handles part in the double yellow lines
and I don't cry anymore because there
are 12 and on yellow he went through
back your father that's what most of you
know they don't actually go into the
gumbo and parking bays right counselor
nice what Couture to come back the
offered we meet you hiding probably
because they call you would get charged
hence its I think it's better to have
him in the car park and from the par-4
double yellow lines you know everywhere
else on the streets and just one other
question and Penny tell me how much
difference it would make the change from
the six o'clock seven o'clock and on how
much we be doing because if the amount
of returning from six to the seven is
small then it's going to cost twenty
thousands of pounds to change the signs
it's better to leave it alone through
our particular time nothing I know that
whatever like the same but I say if we
if we don't change it and leave it at
seven o'clock then we won't have to pay
20,000 pounds to alter it rich so we can
still up free parking from seven till
whenever rather than from six because
we're going to lose twenty thousand five
by changing the order the cost is 10,000
pounds the actual lots of income would
appear to be 20,000 pounds so we left it
as it was we wouldn't have to pay 20,000
pounds to change your yeah so the amount
of money that we lose would be nothing
Oh guess if mr. scruff and coming i
would guess that if we're changing the
order anyway wouldn't easier you know me
is the cost of changing an order that
you just change the order once or do you
have to do in order to saturday the
opposite after six or it would just be
an all inked up so if you just do it if
we do any of these things it will cost
the same amount roughly for the parking
order if you would do if you were to
meet more than 100 if it's the council
ultimately agreed to make more than one
change those changes will be part of
minority and will cost it yeah and one
cost ya such do any changes would cost
about twenty that would cost around
10,000 l's regardless so if you're
making one change that the additional
second change would have a opportunity
cost of neil but we still may be serving
ten thousand pound they're off secluded
gonna cost ten thousand how am i going
to earn twenty and make 10,000 for 2010
the resilient be 10,000 random error on
I'm sorry case little wooden counselor
make some info nice couple of things
first of all them our seniors is not
just main campus also serviced residence
so it's a two-pronged approach to this
so I'd like to look at it that way the
other thing was about disabled I want to
bring up the business basis of
disability in my house or the question
first is it used to be that when someone
had known blue ticket and they felt on
about them limited to two hours and a
his ex still the sign before it was that
gone it's gone out the window who's that
that longer long is this the wo lines
you parked on you pot industry wm rogers
book broke up and you had two hours in
which to free park I think yet come back
didn't you showing yes I think I think I
just create little um not absolutely
sure where those two or three two or
three idea but that is the case if that
is the case because it raises the
question we're talking about free
parking or die according to this because
it says free parking ammonia which
currently I think women are disgusting
we were to give them two hours would we
not for know why or was it because I
wasn't suggesting that we allow in
network was suggested by somebody that
our concession to get back you with me
there was a suggestion made where they
pay for an hour for they turn our
attention but look everybody off here
might be my body it was it was just a
common I'm just saying if you can own
parking all die for free when at the
moment you've got sacked for a house in
that scurry bad deal was it yeah I made
the suggestion that Robin gets get one
hour free parking for people may notice
that you give one out for every are they
fighting or basic you double the time
they pay home that was asked if I made
of the if I may miss chillin I'm just a
little bit cautious to get this a very
disabled people will go on the train to
London embarcadero ops they've all that
buys out all those are free when I
travel to London if I might be a bit
cynical I'm going to be concerned that
all or solely we should have some
control if I just say something on the
blue badge holders you something I
director says about whole supports going
forward to the packet personally however
when you I have looked around in large
number of councils and how they deal
with it and there's a tendency not to
have all or nothing there's a tendency
to have some car parts in which you can
park for free and other car parts where
you will be challenged in there be no
concessions so for instance car pops
near a station may well be charged for
where
part which is in central shopping center
Mike will be free mr. Chen be familiar
though it seems very complex system I
think it's easier just programming from
the back down and say these are the
rules and implies to everybody I would
like to say personally some control over
time it is that why you're just giving a
freebie to anybody really we're that
knee sock I know what can do that put a
proposal for would feel so I think thing
we got remember this these proposals are
to benefit people approximate and to
financial implications are a secondary
issue breathing if it makes the council
worse off then obviously we can't go hit
it makes the money that we can the for
proposals that are there in my view
benefit very few people i think free
parking up sick in I don't think now
yeah I played praying for people that
won't make sure our but that he's going
to do it all for a lot I don't you go to
beat I speak what's going to town and
our early curse you in shop sharp five
and half five understands every evening
economy but that doesn't mean a start
six o'clock we've only been home from
work free parking debris bare shoulders
I'm sorry I think through guys I was
there's not that many of them and I
wouldn't be there simply want them
parking all dying except standing
they've moved they need more parking
space is not longer parking free parking
to sell Christmas you know again I think
yes a bit added bonus but I would point
out the free parking off I would assume
the pre-poll King for the two surfaces
off the Christmas would have a Nilla
cost because I should we could be on the
park in order which is for the assuming
it is done the free parking before
Christmas tomorrow I'm just thought I
think New Jersey should head to my dear
sorry what Jesus cross i'm sorry may
help selling that lately that the
current arrangement look which goes on
an opponent by the new by you basis of
the dispensation insect is before
christmas is is relatively modestly
priced because we can do that in the
basis of a temporary here changed it
into the order but but clearly and if if
the council ultimately decided that
there should be changed safe from 6-7
p.m. to six pm and that had to be
different if that would have to be
yeah well as a as a as a change to be
clear that moving from maybe tutor from
for two weeks to six weeks could be done
on to the temporary I will suggest that
you probably don't be doing the same
result cotton see many more so I
canceled Mason thank you and I wasn't
able to he's tell you this the full
council wind our parking was discussed
in fact I was shut up but i think if we
do with your familia as i'd say no the
regime with regards of blue badge
holders has changed dramatically in
essence the assessment is now incredibly
stringent basically you don't get a blue
badge on review unless basically you
can't walk and that is about the bottom
line bruh I know because when I was
unwell I went through the assessment
believe me if I was considerably a
mobile but not enough to have a blue
badge I could just about what ten yards
that was ok so don't run away with the
apprehension that there are going to be
in the future a lot of blue badge
holders around no not they really won't
be there won't be because the rules have
changed I'm also very concerned that we
don't know how much I I really don't
like open blank checks I just don't do
those sort of things so i can't i can't
take that on the the issue with 6pm was
about encouraging people to come neat
and it was not about the evening economy
the clubs and and everything else when
he was discussed three or four years ago
counselor Blackwood's actually the ones
mostly to it that he was talking about
there being a lot of restaurants in
rayleigh for instance and in fact by now
there are a lot of restaurants in Hawk
well and they're also ones in hockley
and Rockford in various places so it was
considered to be something that would be
worthwhile to diamonds and we may be
encouraged them to dive early and it
made me film restaurants a little
earlier maybe through restaurants a
little earlier than they could have
their tables circulated for later times
so that many putting that forward is
something that we've not put forward
this evening and council blacks not here
I'm not changing my mind I still quite
content with after 6pm being creepy and
they're being to free parking saturdays
in the new year so we do well I mean
evening entertainment so I wasn't
restricted active for like nany in Simon
Pegg blues restaurant across the choice
of which I enjoyed this is for certain
I'm raining and I you know the big bear
my comment about three bear shelters was
that we need more blue bed spaces rather
than just the limited spaces into
parking labeled oh yeah I'm feeling that
I will um sum up in I think the
consensus is and please shatter me if
I'm wrong is that the free all day
Saturday coughing we're not none of a
suit to agree on that is accurate
alright that appears being read i think
visited look at dover take notes on this
or not down so i think we just go
through the others one by one we know
the vote on it because then i certainly
have a different views to other people
as well i would point out the free
parking after 6pm on
WIC days would cost the council 20,000
pounds in income and will also cost the
council an additional 10,000 pounds of
the changing pulp and changing parking
order but the 10,000 would be a one-off
costs only the 20,000 would be an annual
Iranian costs vary mind that the idea of
this is that the parking charges that
appear to be raising more money than was
originally suggested and it was some
audience i think the architects game has
been muted by the chamber trading radio
at least so that that's where they argue
that certainly comes from some extent
and so all those who want to put forward
to the 2067 budget the idea of free
parking after 6pm on weekday evenings
thanks and all those who do not want to
put that forward so what were they do
this time for five four and four against
so yeah 5454 right would you still
five-four right yeah okay thank you said
I'll be football showcase at ease is
going other free parking for blue badge
holders a day night oh I agree with this
but I think we are just lacking
information personally so we'll take a
vote on that those four at this point in
time and those games which i understand
the settling i'll be putting forward and
then the free parking two sets after
christmas have lots of income of 4,000
pounds there would be minimal cost for
this because the cost has already been
incurred on the proviso that the four
seconds before christmas are done so
those in favor of putting that one
forward for the budget
those against any abstentions one
abstention thinking but thank you so to
summarize the ones that we're putting
forward for the budget process of free
parking off 6 p.m. weekdays and free
parking to such as elf christmas deco
intercepts I'm i think that's you've
done if you able to actually nicer one
well then leave this obviously have a
big contribution yeah thank you for
coming
the the next one is now homelessness and
it's to consider the responses of
questions race of the last meeting of
the community they may I should have a
sheet giving the details i'm not sure
pounce the Seekers has their countries
pursued which is the list of questions
that were asked or given firm printout
homelessness question so that's what you
get I unless I just make sure you had
guys that's all yeah thanks right so to
consider the reports right wrong bit
there consider the response you so I've
had the responses are around the
trafficking is in 52 feet what do you
want to cover mates to gather your
thoughts
or perhaps loot leave answer the
questions so confrontation there's a lot
of information of course yes if I just
laid office Sorry Sorry found this is
what you want a bagel but you weren't in
position i think that previous meeting
so he's probably fear you've made
yourself familiar with the questions
usually we try not to know about you i
think the questions were answered faye
comprehensively there's there are some
additional points which i think people
need to know which are towards the end I
think a particular interest lot it may
be the last page and the 14 I feel
personally that this Mayweather our
other items that or additional items
which we clapped on to store more fully
which we're not going to be able to this
meeting so I think what we're looking
now is a question of anything we bring
forward from the answers we had to these
questions you really think we think as I
committed me to bring forward to the
next incarnation of the review committee
so catch them listen I don't want to
talk about these individual are
questions a nun but I'm actually haunted
by something that cancer a butcher say
that it was the end of last meeting the
subject sheets you actually say you
didn't ask the portfolio what her views
were and what other actions she might
wish to take on Homer Spit I was very
embarrassed by that and because it
embarrass me i didn't forget so it's a
shame that council the person isn't
tonight for us to ask that question and
without that bracket questions if you
like and I wonder whether I'd like to
recall the fact that we didn't I'd like
to record the fact that I'd like to have
the opportunity to answer that those
questions and maybe we can invite it to
consider sending a note back to the
review committee yes my two was struck
by the remarkable as well you did stick
in my mind that we did fail to ask the
obvious question and we get along we
just a cutlet engine father make
Mother's Day not so much to do with the
report here but the thing I was talking
about originally I still have know that
probably answer is the strategy of here
I thought leader power homeless persons
per side I mean there was a meeting
today I didn't take their mind to take
care so we brought the district council
place and others which I wasn't they
when they were discussing what to do
about people around the 10 who they're
fine you know sleeping rough etc I still
comes down to homelessness for me and
all these things are we about housing
you know how much is costing us or but I
would it and I bit more about the
machinery I wanted about it more
bearable
about homelessness yeah as a general
there is a strategy yeah oh man top it
which we have read I'm sure people a bit
to immediately doing day on the band is
your life and decided that you believe
that strategy isn't is too vague exactly
right so I don't know so what you
interacting well yes I sorry I mean
every day very clearly I was here and I
seem to recall Kent alone and that use
indicated last meeting that you would
find it useful to spend some time with
the with the dolls this team and what we
do I have to organize that that may very
well help answer some of the questions
that you've got you know actually seeing
and speaking to the officers who deal
with the these matters on a day-to-day
basis and she was chewing your subscribe
to feed off of me the opportunity to go
down as pendant idea and I've to Pradesh
I haven't done that so I wonder if you
leave in their point but maybe you could
try to be able to get more might be left
in your court yes perhaps to do that
yeah um casal Hagel saw would think as a
try how many different ways is there the
title homelessness do watch for it to be
different to everybody else or do
everybody else very different to us in
their age one absolute good strategy is
probably because I'm obviously I believe
other councils to be differently
is that correct or is there just one
strategy fits all and you adapt it or if
you're just one policy but I government
sound and we all follow it as best we
can goodbye you don't have a bit of it I
think I think the answer is probably yes
and no I mean in the set in the sense
that yes you know we've got to follow a
series of rules but you know there may
be local nuances within that in terms of
trying to adjust the system or a new on
the system to to do as much as we can
for a rock forward you know all this
beat them but I think basically you can
follow up you know I purpose and rules
and I suspect that if you look at the
homelessness strategy for a ruptured and
compare it to other authorities you know
there will be a huge elements of
similarity between bismuth between them
so this one gets our attention also if
the son of no reason say full of water
company was the main benefactor of this
area and they closed down and everybody
became of us and will that be a problem
who pays for I know somebody comes from
government and center button
ultimately if that happened in this area
would they be a huge amount of money
lost by the tunnel school because it
couldn't afford to but after all and
people be good I mean I'm yet a loss is
through the answers yes or a natural
side obviously with a disaster and
obviously be a disaster fund or
something like that but you know if you
are very prosperous and then all of a
sudden found yourself the this area
became very poor and we are huge amounts
of people of this could be cold or how
would we come with a situation like my
favorite food and this this obviously
helped us to to prove that we could if
we had to do what is necessary
okay I'm an advocate leeadams of Judas
of it any comes to meet minimal thing I
think if you were hit by you have made a
deluge of of homeless people you know
hundreds and hundreds of all those
people it would it would be an issue I
don't presume cuddles any case about
that i mean i think if you if you even
from the basic perspective of say well
look how would you deal with hundreds of
homeless people in terms of just bed and
breakfast accommodation it doesn't exist
you know and so therefore i think you
would have to take a view on pardon me
to what emergency measures would be
required in that in that particular
circumstance you know and i don't know
what it might need bringing bringing
either one of these some hotel bar
cheese about the tens and moving off sir
things or something I practing I don't
know a little bit but in that sort of
situation in clearly in a women to look
to see what they have what the worldly
here but what the way of what the way of
addressing that would be necessarily
very easy oh my god is he freaking
obtainable I mean if that happened for a
short period of time yes you might be to
come but it can happen for a long period
forever reason we could be bankrupt the
count
done for me I'll fair to question room
until it can be written go bankrupt
actually chairman the area's putting
stickers staring and give like with the
flowers I think the risk would be no
amount of money folks on the plantations
casa drank the name calculor Burton
visibly our strategy though would be
based on our strategy statutory ring
obligations unless we embellish those
obligations for what we feel the people
in dentistry want us to do in respect of
homelessness but is there any minimum
statutory obligations that we have to
adhere to consume you ouch reported lost
on I can't remember which question
so I will mommy are ultimately boils
down to whether we've got a few gia heat
or whether someone is intentionally all
this and you know that's but that if
that process of assessment is one that
is challenging things probably a wee wee
favor it's you don't hate so being that
that's all some of these is the test and
if people trying to be intentionally
homeless then we will not have a duty to
to find an accommodation can I come back
of a view my cam burgers we may not have
an obligation but to help them
nonetheless or do we want all right
direction we provide them in housing
advice you do if we don't if you can't
provide them it's a temporary
accommodation we do provide the
apartment housing advice and fell into
other agencies are necessary because the
Burton and I think that looking to the
questions the answers presented earlier
I think they're all perfectly acceptable
below make complete sense I have so for
me personally that go into the last
meeting my concerns are still roughly
the same I don't feel they were
adequately addressed or perhaps I just
didn't understand houses and those two
poor point where to pull it with them I
had concerns about the number of units
that were available it seems to me like
we were always short and we've always
beneficial so that is like really really
a beautiful depending what I thought I
wish it was both really and it wasn't
didn't seem to be solution that just
seems to be an accepted thing I had
concerns about the number of units are
actually
humans because term logic is at work the
number of units that are outside the
district I'm not in the district and I
still like that concern even look at it
information in here I still think
there's a very high percentage of
outside the area and also how we as a
district go about seeking new
accommodation are we just reliant on
outside bodies that already provide
accommodation to just say to us or we've
got some more they're available do or do
we actively go out trying to find I with
actionable react are we to do we go out
looking for extra ones are we always
noted is that a thing that's down on
earth six monthly basis is it an ongoing
role in thing or a program and don't
really those those were the queries I
had been that kind of the quiz I have
now done okay then castle which is
capable Thank You channel and the answer
to question 12 concerning children
returning year old school it's only way
we can find out how accommodating as its
kind of count /er police requests it is
as you can apply but they're quite
strict about hanging out for children's
travel to score anyway but we any way of
knowing how phase would be those actual
applications and I looked or no are they
are they do they say well you're on a
bus route will give you extra the bus or
even if that's not practical if mum's
got baby in a buggy a toddler and a
school-age child will cover that we got
any by finding out more information then
if I can aid
it okane seems to be left up to the
person who's being made homeless to
apply it says applicants can apply so
I'm wondering do we provide assistance
to that and what sort of assistance do
we provide all we do we just direct them
to another agency we provide assistance
and I will find out we get statistics on
how many have been successful in how
it's been done very another osarian for
a [ __ ] if I feed be pouring iced mocha
Chris but to me how business is a great
cross average of tools the has a
strategy with housing you know and it's
you come and run muddies of already
other lil bit because if you haven't got
one surprise faulty Barney and then you
end up in bed breakfast and all sorts of
things it seems to me that there's a
very close relationship and would you
keep talking about homelessness but we
need to look at housing a generally
arousing needs generally and i think i
think really very very were climbing
when I would keep asking all these
questions but we
we can't do everything with such limited
resources and i remember when i worked a
car supporting algo valve your hands in
there none of our business if you know
we have things like rent deposit schemes
i'm sure you're familiar with Edmund
where where people for the benefit
papers of living in accommodation
includes cooking to people or they
wanted to move and they're quite happy
to go into private coordination but
couldn't raise the deposit the cancer at
you gave them a deposit as a rent
deposit so I cake did the property they
found their cell somewhere else to live
we're gonna need positive so everybody
was happy but it made accommodation
available for neat so I think that
there's people about fallible housing
and all these things but I think we need
to look within the strategy of housing /
site and say to ourselves that these are
pigs are linked without you can't
separate availability and accommodation
you've got to put them together and i
know will be talked about how many so
how much this for me it's how we deal
with people who are homeless but we seem
to be dying deal with entune
accommodation we have available and I
mean this business about assisting
people so awfully support there that
should be for everybody to meet his
friend should be open all of that
residence in this way and so we are
personally got to send bigger control if
you like of the bull goes on the past
another chair Tamela excitement I think
that a child closely linked the one
supports the other also write something
about these morons everything I was
absolutely there in there in lies and
interesting and controversial suddenly
there was little bit that there is
actually a draft homes strategy we seeks
to bring together an update of the of
the strategy in relation to the duties
responsibilities that but linked also
with work from the problem with the
planning for c-section so hopefully that
battle-ax marriage blinking like a very
shortly i could I at this point if we
want to which might be appropriate
springing now you do have a cup a few
items on the clean decision documents
sure switching clue yet well you
probably feel reference i was mentioning
it yeah which is why you take to do a
lot of other people say i did the
implementer that start off by making a
minute which one is the refined
appealing because if I neighborhoods one
is the empty homes of strategy which is
a tow for 15 min page 3 of the P
decision document 1315
Oh to go for 15 now only buildings
another that's another housing out
whilst that backwards not be mean okay
in my number even so I'll go the other
way then over to 15 which is the housing
allocations some degree which the
decision is to be made this month would
that be made this month public and
whether I think therefore in so if you
should units a portfolio that's I think
we won't be a tit to in shortly and the
same for thee then we have the empty
home stranger and that would be the same
with it which is like trying something
the parapet in advance is something we
have to review on for so I have some
excellent the reason i mention OT 15 is
going to really understand what each
other so as we've got oh you they offer
this is from if you are did you without
telling me what's in it tell me what the
scope is which one get their jobs my 15
housing application i'm not quite sure
what it means so you're doing the
Housing Register I'll doing something
else it it relates to the arrangements
for how we deal with with with certain
aspects of the the housing losing list
and the allocation narrow so for example
how long must someone wait and be
resident in the district before they
qualify to go on there on the housing
list and the intention is to reduce the
list or if the expectation the list will
be reduced and well I think I think the
intention is that the length of time so
we'll have to wait and will be increased
I don't have an idea apologies Jim and I
don't have yet i don't have the talk
with me so I just right now and who says
the prospects of an offer of structure
housing will be reduced so I suppose
that means you could still be on there
for the same length for lot longer but
you're just that's likely to get the
offer yes that sounds like reducing you
the likelihood of someone and around
what basis is that is that on the basis
of residency then revisit the kids yeah
so that would lengthen the residency
requirements would it yes do you know
from what to what and if you easier if
not good Courtney I think it's instance
where a cultural change in three years
is the business because once that it
might be sudden three years or three
years out of 5 I think it's three years
lots of five of them flat three years as
if action figures copy tender glances
and that will change too where exactly
is traps will change to you right from
three out of five to three right
throughout the last one to three times
remembering a career and we'll take your
bangle politics topologies up being
Vegas and I'm not deliberately intended
to be it's just that what when I
originally discusses the the changes
with the portfolio he was actually some
time ago then we quickly the matter on
the on the key decisions list and
sometimes has been passed so we just
need to finalize the report now to go to
the portfolio builder so so I catch the
license I'm just a bit surprised I
listened carefully to that but we won't
talk about this when we load our last
meeting on Florida's out pretty good
blood but I am why weren't we told about
this change because it impacts on just
what we've been actually delving into
the final form of 0 mrs. cruncher I know
I move it up a little where the
questions asked
okay I'll make a longer listening to you
Jacqueline probably Me farting more
resources in useful yes there may be the
pressures make it a little more specific
problem or less Jason zestril I'm not
yeah any other questions on now not
overly happy more self or in the one I
was also interesting the empty home
strategy which I bring into this as well
in September 2014 there are over a
thousand properties in the district
which would be empty for more than six
months that is a fact I'll have the
email from the officer at the time I'm
not sure what the figure is now let's a
significant number of properties does
does the room what have you can you
recall what the report may or may not
say in regard to bring those empty
property to use no okay
what thousand properties about
significant way to reducing or providing
homes for residents and quiet level the
purpose of the purpose of the purpose of
the strategy is to reduce the number of
empty homes in the district there
clearly is never going to be possible to
get the number of long-term NT homes
down to don't assume but in our thinking
recognize of the trip proposals
recognize that there's need to be as
proactive as possible contact landlords
and so on and donors and then sure that
the council does everything it can to
encourage those owners to bring those
properties back to occupation or to sell
them or whatever that might be I think
Joe and if you call the council has
already made changes in relation to
cancel text there was no the sensation
now in relation to empty properties and
you know that they all really have you
know starting to make difference in
terms of fair and honest focus on
they do with an empty property so sick
or something I believe judging by at
least one or two that I know she steamed
rice or neck of the woods great wakering
that the council does in fact to utilize
it sort of ability to bring back
properties that are either in a state of
disrepair or long-term renovation that
have not been occupied I actually
providing funding for the owners of
those properties to bring them up to the
standard where they can be they leased
to the council or to a Housing
Association possibly and then rented out
for a period of five years or whatever I
think maybe agreed so there are schemes
to do that are they are being used for
pleasure that's that's certainly one of
the one of those schemes that was
operates and of course is that you know
in in the past the council has actually
only one at least one or two occasions i
think i can recall actually compulsory
purchase the properties that have been
mistaken for or district here in order
to get them back into into occupation
right thank you tell about oh just
asking there's another one we I think
that's we did touch one button it
doesn't expect them and also in the
areas that you leave that and any other
questions or thoughts i'm getting i
would agree with castle or woman around
the house you stretch junior thing keys
I think you could have more backbone to
your things
perhaps that's something leave it set of
recommendations me review which car is
to choose you natural homes distracted
food source Kathir seekers is stating
the obvious but it sir it would seem
then that members will need to take a
radically different approach to the sort
of house building intentions of this
district today's the case but it seems
that looking around the table i can
think of a number of members that would
not be in favor of that in their
particular wallet certainly and in many
instances anywhere in the district but
is that the obvious I don't know perhaps
not perhaps a Mason I wasn't going to
tap on that but as you have it thanks so
much i hope to get out of this report
and this review something more than we
have a nigerian counselor burn on that
I'm 55 and happy that we're in a
position as a committee to put anything
forward to the executive I think there's
a great deal more for us to do there's a
great deal more for others to answer and
there's other things we need to see and
while we're on that subject there was of
course an interesting manifest at the
pump is today I will know I'm sure you
already I'm sure you know the
implications the implications will be
that in terms of affordable homes you
work the built a great deal more that
being the case
have an interesting dilemma we've got a
problem with Housing Register getting
longer and I'd like to think that I'm a
merciful person I'm interested in those
people who live in my district I'm
interested in seeing the young people
I'm interested in seeing those without
regular homes to have the opportunity to
have them if we have to to accommodate
them and nobody else build some houses
or give some permissions then fine but
I'm afraid I'm not prepared to agree a
huge trade offs for massive sways of
greenbelt so you're right if you look
around the table and expected that
response so we've got a bit of a problem
we've got an OA n which won't deliver
until the end of 2015's their correct
masters from we are a in being produced
by consultants it's the it's the it's
the it's the change set of circumstances
around the schmuck we don't have
tomorrow wishing i was part 2 2013 it
was replaced by an RA in so I'm kind of
expecting that our way into tell me
something about what an independent
consultant feels that we need to provide
for our local needs and those local
needs I would like to know about our
young people I'd like to know about
those who don't have homes and roll
regular homes I'd like to know about you
know older people as well I want to know
about those things but in the meantime
we have people with our homes and what I
would like to see is review committee do
is find some immediate and short-term
changes that we can undertake as a
council to improve their
thank you you're so secretive and
intrigued by the reference to rates ways
of Greenville could you define that
please I think we are broadly aware of
what the core strategies already done
and we know I know from the analyses
I've done that there's probably a
minimum another fifteen hundred houses
that we need to find to keep to the
rates of growth that we said we would so
I'm sure you can work out the number of
the hectare and work out on amount of
Greenville will need to be released if
there isn't brown belt them and we have
a and we have the directory job planning
sitting there so we didn't work around
seven if it helps is less than one
percent of the Bible where I've done
enough tell me how many hectares hitters
chillin yeah it's about a hundred each
set email I would surface I think I'm
not sensitive how many Hector must
believe is just a rather a little rock
that 100 hectares thank you for that but
I like that's recorded a little better
great sway dear email too late no I'm
glad that's recorded and we will leave
that there before we get into a debate
around the post registry and when it's
going to be reviewed again so it can
sabotage expecting that only not by the
beginning of this conversation well
we're not going to go back to cancel a
person yes we are going back to cancel
McPherson at all so you go back could we
ask us any questions perhaps some
concert by thinking ahead we've still
get clearer down I believe the question
that information check is very good
and I think probably all those people at
that meeting with a gray that we should
ask that of councilman person I
personally think that your question of
the three questions you are Soviet will
act as well and should be asked I my
problem is that I think we've barely
scratched the surface with it mr gu and
i think possibly what we we can do at
the moment is ask the questions and ask
those to come back to the next review
quitting is that the agreement of them
yeah the panel I don't know what I think
the problem is there's a lot of unknowns
in here still I think it's a very big
subject and we haven't magic I'd
probably also recommend the paps that
the members of the new brief review
committee I don't know who's going to be
on it should perhaps take out the offer
if we are going to review if you review
is going to take on the homies this
again to take up the offer of spending a
day and watch Alicia cows rhythms
capsule almond you're going to if they
want to find out more that be acceptable
yeah Green is that ok anyone anything
else dared please add something if you
want to apart from core strategy which I
know is relevant but we will get to the
facts about that that's a lighter that's
why cats little would educate on them
it's receiving a special you're going to
follow up with or consuming more listen
and I think that I don't think we're in
a position to really pull this through
for you know he's in his current way
I like to see it to be a bit more
interactive bit more aggressive if it
affects their work whatever expression
you want to use and maybe a smaller
treatment trimmed packages group of the
committee could get interactive with
people like housing but like we talked
about and even with all the questions
and answers we can go and interrogate
and get some of these answers and see
what's going on because all seem to do
in this make first day we kick out of
meetings asking a lot of questions with
which we get reply then we come back to
the next week will be invent another
load of questions when we go away get
another dollar facing we get another
letter replies and it's just snowballs
and an eye for one I'm losing track of
where I am so I'd like to sing
personally a smaller group a little bit
more assertive gaining with the offices
members officers what the ones if you
like your gain in there came to know
each other find out what's going on to
come back with a bit of a factual base
library based on their questions are
being asked that's why we recommend that
to the well we'll ask the questions come
back to review committee and that can be
real people fortunately review quitting
job done thank you is that no fish oh
sorry castle Hazelwood very nice quick
point house of yours should go on this
cause I love that's what suggested
ultimately it's a unless we understand
and fully man then just take it a couple
of us and we're about the rest of us
just going to sit here like Tammy's no
heed my new carry on with us from a
question nothing coming we're all here
for the same reason to find that what's
going on surely so I'm Stan capsule
almost pointing that it could be a good
thing for a working group to do there's
no harm in other members of the review
committee all who aren't alright able to
do that tool so I don't think any home
for any counselor to find out about
how we work around home I apologize
chapter the idea i'm saying it's amazing
individual imma get booked more bit more
evidence bags instead of sitting around
here so flying area that's really what
it's really like a green thing back
already i'm also interested in five even
though i might not be on that little
creepy but obviously we're all here to
cuddle it went absolutely okay which is
listed if you could actually one point
powerpoint and then we really key yes
yes it's fine for the committee to find
out how they almost esteem works but it
needs to be done in a careful a burner
dropline body clearly the team is
working you know and even though they
don't have a lot of time to yeah I'm
turn to despair so you know that needs
to be done careful to get so i'm not
sure the whole community there could be
there is just business so sorry okay
okay video right Thank You faster five
or six done the jawbone era Cody that's
fine it's also a sin to be decision we
discussed so yeah we did those any other
problems too many months view
you can take it we now move on to the
review of the ICT contract we have
reported review proceeding project team
which is item seven volume Clarys the
recommendations flip on a 747 flight
following and are as red dryer is
written out to up just reading people
read I would add that this report has
been sent to the portfolio holder
counselor mrs. Lucas Gill and she has
not responded to it that's all right
this is taken quite some time miss put
it on the first ones we stopped having
its melted into an oil and iPad under
the ICT want to become a male bear makes
it into my report at the end of it and
it is an interesting report or just
taking questions or points from anyone
anyone or are we accepting all the
recommendations okay I'll go and break
out those mayhem three what do you mean
by Lana not be any show item three on 74
that's over there nothing for them
um up appearing website yeah I'm
Stanford was discussing the bill where
of this I stand up just am over een this
thing this is the director is aware of
this because it's happened to make you
know have to have a virgin as well yeah
things happen to other people as well
we're on I have and I'm refusing to
remove them myself on our nearly three
pages of apps which I do not consider
appropriate to be on my counsel iPad
which include a number of games which
have appeared on there all right so I
can show them you I've got that although
ideally my object identity to the method
i would say i deleted mind the first
time but i have on today that is its do
it can be slightly embarrassed any file
in the council chamber cause people will
click through my life echoes that moves
the poet make think I've download all
these games myself but I'm not deleting
them I want to know why they're there so
cows the drain showing is it not a kiss
a case of them being blocked come live
counsel mr. Mowbray rule on to those
apps on coming lunch where I was going
to run busters I do leave sugar and I
think if if my memory serves are
correctly and making then we get told
such a technicalities on this don't we
no members have taken correctly it
relates to the issue of the
generic login that has been used and
that that appears to be causing apps he
downloaded on other right heads so
secluded as the sort of some of that
there is their loading them and then but
that's their duplicating hardly download
and upon other or another right guys I
mean after Apple is interesting company
in the sense i'm going to want one
counselor Tony told me the other day
that he decided to have a clearer on
ease of suffering he's on his iPhone and
then horror of Horrors look to his iPad
discovered that you know a feature of
Apple is that it duplicates those
actions on all devices so they don't
disappear from from from the iPad as
well which was not intended and so so I
listen this is this is you know feature
of the feature two sovereign and it
seems to relate to the way that we ruled
them out yeah an ankle to genuine sorry
to interrupt that could be taken care of
our turn to other recommendations which
is the equation except generika profiles
for installations each one would have
their own construction casa Berta
Newcastle almond just come back to this
form you said that it had been since the
full file yes when was that do you know
and when we fully expecting a response
prior to this meeting no we were just
giving her the courtesy of seeing the
role okay I from my quite a few as
chairman we were providing the report to
the portfolio hon hold on the
understanding that he gave the portfolio
an opportunity to come back if there was
something that the propeller did not the
gradebook thought was wrong or thought
which represented the situation that was
my funeral
so castle Albany cast the train in hmm
now it is referred to the other message
cause people watching important it was
in we know it is and all the rest of it
getting this has nothing to do with me
many questions can we are a team can we
have the question I'm just putting in a
security because you talk about apps
getting on other people's machines I'll
get messages and nothing to do with may
four of you I think there's something
you need to take up as no else and I
think that's a technical items so you
need is going to speak to you need to
use the free phone number any-any
idiosyncrasies in terms of things
appearing on devices needs to be
reported through the appropriate
channels so that the issue can be taken
can be checked and resolved if there is
a beautiful pin okay umm qasr Drake just
one point on on that on that terms
chairman the appropriate channel would
be capital e Jessica of the unwary never
coming back to the the fact that the
portfolio holder is seen as report has
not responded who can we take
two degrees in the content
I couldn't say that I've hope so down
folks
it may be that they may agree with it or
may feel that they don't agree of it but
don't want to bring it back to the
review something I don't know I couldn't
comment was that very hasn't come back
for me it's all about put words in their
mouths gen-y digital to comment on that
curly just could you just recap on how
long ago it was scented sorry off top
results and it was sometime in early
March is no civil tongue yeah so if you
want to come back as the train goes
there and all I can say is that
obviously a lot of work went into the
review of the ICT contract and the iPads
and their various meetings and I think
the I suppose recommendations the
reported I get so I cattle Mason and
that thank you and I I also support the
recommendations in the report because I
was there and these are the
recommendations that were put forward by
the task and finish group I just like to
comment further on the issue why this
report was shown to the portfolio elder
and if I remember correctly and it was
only reported to me I was not there
at the executive when the first report
was submitted the portfolio hold had
been claimed that she had not seen the
report that was going to be submitted to
the executive beforehand and she
disagreed with so many things that were
in it that he was actually sent back to
us so the task and finish group
recommended that the report was shown to
the portfolio holder so that there won't
lose me misunderstandings I this
occasion but of course these
recommendations need not be accepted by
the portfolio holder nor the executive
favorable so did you commit there's no
other than artists Alden ok so can are
we content too difficult stove folders
stated in the recommendation thank you
set foot for some football then it's a
great little place pigs you in Bachmann
just like that one time little bit
longer happy I think we've done mostly
anyway that's that all yours so 0 1 15
commercial use of car parks charging and
[ __ ] anyway this is another April 2015
reporting sure must be very busy it's
late for 2015 so I've shooting that is
for the charging of things like
potentially things I screen phones
burger vans will have been car park
that's good yeah or fish dilution I
think when those better than including
lie
screening breast cancer screening for
another Upton Park up in car parks we do
one it up kiddo yeah I'm shipping out
exclusive probably most intelligent such
a thing it's all folks okay it's not
commercially i say i don't know if it is
or not I may not get the Opera
imperative shot open egopay happy free
no hey easy yeah it's good over time to
them and they can be specific for this
food thing about be noted in order you
can ask so is it not limited asked to
clarify what they were just happen fast
oh yeah sorry we don't know but let's
show with student non-committal type in
my opinion so appreciative going forward
Jim later any of the NCAA straight up so
that's a question would you come back
for it let's get frustrating the
language is the last meeting actually 15
I think housing allocations I think
we've said what we've seen is it will
just raising the council fate your fate
empty shops stretch drink any comment
it's intended to be it is intend to be
towed been able to cancel to be
a little bit ly proactive in terms of
seeking to deal with empty shops though
we've not got a significant number of
any shops in the industries that have a
movie which is a good thing or a hot
spots of them I'm not particularly
limited I don't think that you know
these these these things go in cycles of
them and it just intended to put some
tools in place to enabling it's
believable proactive in terms of trying
to deal with these linearize okay I 550
I think okay weirdo I'm sorry did you
want to come by yourself is the correct
about the open empty shop strategies
would that mean liaison with for
instance the town teams and the Chamber
of trying Mike yes mate all over the
sorts of things Lee they were trying to
attract them landlords find out what the
issue is it might be as has been used in
it sometimes enters from
you didn't being left and unattended in
looking very sad you know that perhaps
you know we get shot displays in the
windows or posters on every missiles a
number a number of ways that perhaps
from the impact of empty shops can be
really rated sorry what this all types
of lot for there's no jobs as well I've
got massive great poster that I'm saying
for sale or services obviously how would
you impact on that I mean the only way
is to remove it surely I mean I wouldn't
have thought whenever you put in it
should empty shop which has got a
massive great post on it saying for end
and with well I think we look talk about
detail of a policy up again during our
jobs generally suggested it might be
that actually rather than having a
poster of look like that it might be
possible to to reach an agreement with
the with the landlord or the owner that
you know that the thing we got in a
slightly more sympathetic wait and we
know perhaps artwork but still be there
with the other fear this is the message
got everything out but it is one in
talking that's been dead for six months
or more but its massive great post on it
I think it was a Chinese table of
something that is to produce just order
another way of giving that might he be
about problem all but as our so
to removal I think I 50 for 15 we've
done empty home directories to think
this is really about 550 probably touch
on that much before which is the homes
strategy over a few framework doing with
the elves and emails and housing need
within the district I think that's what
council Mason's I'm not referring to
some extent time I'm not sure that it
does you see this is where this
described can help me because this isn't
what i was talking oh this is not the
oam it's not far this is something else
and scrutiny you probably benefit me for
the reminder and the committee it does
you know how the two things are
different all the time well i mean i
think that your reference to oriented
folk philip for those members who are
not aware that's objectively assess need
which is a process that is built into
strategic housing market assessments in
order to determine what the what the
need for housing in in the district it
is the government sets some some
guidelines as to how strategic housing
market assessments should be carried out
and how objectively assess a need should
be should be measured in that process is
one that results in a
a document that you know sets out what
the district needs in terms of in terms
of housing over a period of time in this
particular instance it could be 2030 10
a district then does with that that
information its subject then to whole
number of issues probably mainly the
discussions around around planning
policy and either whether the district
feels that that a number of houses
should be accommodated how those houses
might be accommodated what the mix of of
dwellings but might might be and and if
a district determines that you know that
housing need cannot be accommodated for
whatever reason then that is under the
current rules intended to then stimulate
a debate under the duty to cooperate
with neighboring authorities to to
understand where that housing might be
might be delivered as as as an
alternative to to the to to the district
so that's the process that has to be
followed and the homes strategy is is
seeking to its after that event it's
either I'm seeking to do a lot of things
like perhaps influenced and the mix of
affordable houses that might be provided
on on
allocated sites so for example you
recall within the reports that come
forward on for housing development
children call those usually a report
from our our housing colleagues to
indicate whether or not the links of
affordable housing proposed is is
acceptable or not given the housing need
within within the district so I could
ask a question or nothing because that
would that imply that our so fairly
general 35-percent might be less general
and David there would be much Debbie
much more targeted for for within the
strategy itself so they could be
variable it would be a variable one it
might lease either now perhaps yay i
think this variable I mean we asked you
know our housing colleagues look you
know use thirty-five percent of the the
total number of dwelling to the poorest
you know what is the mix of you you know
you would prefer to see to best address
some of the housing need within the
district so notice that the process
that's volatilities it is flexible you
know in the sort of X but it's intended
to be informed by you know the the
information that we have the announces
that we haven't
thank you so handsome Mason yes I wasn't
thanks of that and you know it's been
eight is useful to see those things tied
together but you spoke about the
strength the housing strategies that are
bridges for this council and other
councils which is a shower on our way in
which is which one is going to inform
this how they how whole strategy
although is what's going to come we're
embarking on in your own strategy but I
don't know what's changed so what has
changed and will inform it differently
too we've had before and the wrong
strategy is is not intending to intend
it to be something that is directly
influenced by the the Sh'ma were at
least the chimay look what what will
happen is that that work will influence
the your local plan policy framework and
that interbred influence the the housing
or the whole strategy is we've called it
that will then you take that information
and and as a explained perhaps adjust
the the requirements for the different
type different sizes of units within a
new housing development or so there's a
slightly different end of the reason I'm
coming back is because I am genuinely
confused which is not too difficult for
people to to really take take on board
are we saying we don't have a home
strategy and this is the first one
following the core strategy of the
allocations that right yo you ever had
you have a losing strategy was but but
it it's indeed was 2014 so this is
intended to be an update of that so it
so that 2014 end date strategy did not
take into account the core strategy and
the allocation site they're slightly the
whole double the housing strategy as
wars the vaginal four dem dey the woods
was a strategy that dealt with the
council's responsibilities in relation
to housing and some of the issues that
you you you know you've been talking
about earlier on that this evening so
it's a slightly different beast from the
planning policy framework that picks up
and addresses the issue of housing
numbers yes I understand that
so this Holmes strategy which is listed
here will be informed by the core
strategy and allocation of sites it does
include material from the existing
course tet chaje citation absolutely
okay and we're getting for would inform
any review of the poor strategy or any
reserve the poor strategy trained and
influenced the home stretch tree or
would we be a weedy it would be
influencing by the renewal plan with you
sorry any so that would be if this would
be a item which would be under constant
review then and it will be because I
presume you know we would solve it up
you know to review at the course stretch
Lee Strobel open practically servers you
mean if we're producing this now it will
be updated once though leaves new york
GTG thank you sorry any questions on
that thing understand it now sorry
that's affecting understand the free now
because the next one is and your low E
which is interesting advice services
commission which any comments on anyone
this is a jun 15 report days or
something we couldn't we can't you call
them in these but you can query the more
I'll special influence it's as a drain
for my own benefit I wonder if we will
be given a definition in this context of
what advice services is reading yours
under the pressure it's going to be
something like with them the CIB we've
got that yeah to see anybody you know
and the fact that I think they've always
made no secret of the fact they want
longer term funding because if we'd give
it to a money years basis they can't
play them and I think that's the part of
this and to look at other providers
that's one when they go commissioning it
won't just be able to see I be as I
understanding of these other providers
but this part of it is just to agree the
specification that they're going to go
out on the commissioning job you know
the wcab obviously is the biggest
provider of present yes I'm not sure you
could actually find another four right
here or maybe another provider but
that's Sandra's problem significant so
capsule nice thing in life I was only
going to say that and the fact that this
is a new requirement currently the caap
give us what they want to do this
requirement is a change within the terms
of government policy which requires us
to define what specification is for that
and it is possible that another provider
can come along and completeness which is
the way all of these services
commissioning policies work which is why
we had so many people bidding for all
sorts of services across the end chest
and others good good hit that's
so I thought you might like to be a sign
of course is that the CA B is linked
very closely any type of the
homelessness and housing issues so you
know that that every specification you
know in relation to your delivery of
service needs to take that particular
issue only desire lots of others but you
know that that's one that's particularly
important I think I into the work at CA
be obvious very good point in doing
respective a necessity calls from
housing associations also commissioned
the CIA be around the area catalysis and
housing and I wonder it we actually do
working conjunction we're going to joint
bit have done between them leave that
they are perhaps I've joined up thinking
maybe too much thank you skate two
shipments a very much sorry episode on
don't thank you I would you know last
thing I'll means in the things you can
you look in support of it is or quietly
writers retreat up we've learned a few
staples do but thank you very much for
coming
so the next one is poking my check so
don well which I think we've done the
only one failure fella to pay via social
is they are let's play strip them hold
on young never actually get back foot
holes and we'd have got put we're doing
control comes whistling any comments in
the work thing
this is just talking about looking into
the hair strategy that going to the love
thing that back to the app we cannot
tell the next review which you want to
look at the report for the diet our
texts nothing that we have I think
people here have certain football
nowadays a night or without forward to
the next the dignity if you will think
there is something just find a male in
or break out the drug can I make a
suggestion for perhaps a further
committee to have a look one thing I
like 30 to look at is the income of
possible generation of additional income
for the council from third parties errs
talk about doing work for instance for
other cameras or if their classes is it
worth looking at that to see if we can
generate all dumb or different ideas of
how we can do things I believe that's
one of the areas of the director let me
know so i think that one so accessible
now since our appeal i think that's the
VMP i think perhaps you might be one
that just in that
come on with it certain something the
directors will be to prevent the
directors any Kwajalein if i'll make it
like they then presumably would remain
the other call in on some food yeah or
or if we to get certainly nothing bear
in mind key decisions oh yeah a month
before the month it to see I'm step up I
think it yeah it's always we can put any
wishlist the longer than I think I
probably later I don't it there's big
quite a few things before it already and
I don't want to overload the ideas and
then restrict and then the new review
which you have that maybe feel that they
need never got their own choices in that
respect because that's a little good con
going strategy on thing okay very
important point open the district
employees yes but obviously sorry castle
nice Gemini I understand where the
council during the coming from but you
know this council is running almost two
parts of a spot of three the cabinet and
the offices some support them and
clearly that is an initiative which came
as part of the redesign I think as a
review committee we've got to give them
time and space to execute what was
determined by that policy and I think
were the review committee to take on
that sort of rolla don't thinking thing
turns into review committee
it turns into a cabinet and I think we
can't afford to add two cabinets but we
wouldn't wouldn't be allowed to so
although I fully understand what you
making I think it's one that's going to
come through it may come through as have
been big piece it may come through as
little pieces but I think then the
review committee look so do we are the
best out of it I think nice tight end of
the limbs chairman obviously we've got
the right to review it if we want to end
any member of a review equities got a
right to request a call you not bleep is
up to the chance both since three
members of the review can we can call in
an executive session so it doesn't have
to be a you know one of these Kingdom
citizens over 50 the three of us one we
call it and we can we may i'll discuss
it it's hard to live if it was over
German call in any like right the
chairman of the new committee so there's
plenty of opportunities to bring stuff
back there really a veteran there's a
real name so if you can't fire three
people feel just off the Chairman you
know check post of the preview complete
and lame i will agree
right thank you get the best of us
remember our little thing review
committee and the report
which is there it's quite factual I
what I says I am what's going to write
too forward but in the end I decided not
to write afford to it because I felt it
I might not be neutral enough within
their forward so I iphone decided not to
my think that the report to stand on his
own its effect I don't approve what
other problems okay so i can say nothing
we've been take anybody's thoughts on
report
so just point out the robbing of your
age 10.6 it's 10.1 topics for future
work program that's where I've list it
down and you'll notice I said identified
as possible topics because once again in
steps next year's commence to decide
that um don't miss that building control
yes no this is no solution yeah but
within the yet again i think we probably
need to put ESO SE lo in my so
homelessness the same time is dis of the
night as well because we obviously you
could ask the report to come back to the
next committee so that's something they
will get a report on with a lot local to
music contract sorry for the lady now
birds left we have somebody else take
over we've had few journey I'm not
posters what happy with how they're
running it I think oh and on the going
on opal it is up to the next review
quickly sorry customized occasion is at
the portfolio while a cabinet system
there's a cabin very responsible now we
made a mistake in review committee two
years ago but is that was two years down
but the one before this one is what I
really mean by taking on all the review
of all the contracts that existing I
think it very nearly bust nearly
everybody's capacity for attention for a
long time um I certainly wouldn't wish
to do that again how many bees they ask
i mention that it's obviously because
there was some concerns when virtue is
doing it now the new contractors
obviously taking over how do we know
that any of the things that would
recommend here I'm going to take place
what followed sorella cancel my San go
i'll just say every bull pen holder says
if you've got a question asked me so i
suggest you do what they tell a asked me
to do that's why for ask them the
questions you're unhappy about something
i never said it wasn't happy yet to say
that there was a few questions are asked
a virgin then the other one took over so
we don't know whether they carried on as
virginia or when i meet up on some of
our concerns and opsite sorry
photographing i would say that i was
happy with the response we got from
fusion at the meeting we've got those
points I felt that I being addressed and
I felt that they were investing into the
properties I feel that it's not for this
quiz I think if people want things
brought to review we can actually I
think they need to ask that group leader
to be on the review committee and then
they can bring them forward okay
actually I think they've got a number of
items on their own everyone go I think
it's just asked I think to review the
letter contract for a third year running
more peep it overkill that's so sorry
cathode ray well just on that lose you
lose your contract it has still got a
number of used to run of course isn't it
yes just as a little 24 you
52 zone so cancel all this is a lot of
interesting point of interest to clay an
interest that you join few and i'll
start a countdown edgy when i put aside
i went up there yesterday on stiff
tonight but went over yesterday and i
was told that the end of the wing to be
aware there's a lot trunking and why
regarding into the virginia they're open
all new equipment doing placed in here
and are not been very impressed with
what I've seen to be frank with you you
know and I can't see I think they follow
fulfilling whatever that doubles evident
unlike inside that be politically so
that's what there's no equipment down
here so I don't review fusion again now
that's hope so that's it then be honest
acquit any equipment wasn't like what
was under discussing on my maggots in
any one farthing exercise work dressed
I'd I disagree very gallant Rebecca
sorry anything else on this report so
cathode rice just fun comment which are
is that you mentioned you as a bow
forward on there yes do we need some
sort of conclusion or does the report
together don't speak please I'll let
reports liquor itself I'll I am if the
critics happy i will present the report
at sleep sales meeting which i think i
remember handsome lovely did there are
still areas along i can speak to the
reforms and i was going to speak through
to the report at the council meeting if
that's acceptable well penny was mostly
doesn't actually acceptable to people
but that's why I going to do sorry okay
the other Bart a point I think it stands
for itself and make the few bullets Paco
up but I felt what you want to do the
forward
anything else it is that it no I think
it's fine thank you very much thank you
he look like just know before the total
making just to keep you another night
off the African speech it's my second
year in review my first year chairman
may be my only years to not just like to
take everyone here who's taking part in
the working groups than on the everyone
here is taken by these working groups or
task unfinished groups it can be quite
time consuming and I think everyone's
done a very good job and I'd I think
sometimes the review committee can be
quite difficulty in especially as a if
you're part of the administration if you
like because I think that it feels like
you might be criticizing your own party
but I really want to say that it's not
being the intentional and I hope that's
come across this review but that's not
the idea and I think everyone's actually
looked all the review committees forward
actually done the job very very well not
just that thank you thank you for me
geez that goes thank you
00